quella che vedete la terra il nostro
pianeta bellissimo se guardate
attentamente per quanto attentamente
guardiate non vedrete nessun confine
se noi ci avviciniamo e piano piano
planiamo per arrivare a vedere un
confine
dobbiamo andare in ungheria abbiamo
saputo stamattina che sicuramente non
c'è né di questo tipo a lampedusa in
ungheria noi abbiamo fra posto a una
rete umana che si auto definisce
ungheria un'altra rete umana di persone
che scappano dalla guerra e dalle
persecuzioni e anche spesso dalla
povertà
il sentimento contrario a questo tipo di
movimento delle persone non si limita
alle persone si estende sempre di più
anche a le merci non vogliamo più
importare merci e che spiazzano le
nostre imprese perché sono troppo
competitive
non vogliamo nemmeno più produrre
a livello globale vogliamo trattenere le
nostre imprese vogliamo impedire che
altri presentano il nostro paese questi
sentimenti che un tempo si riassumevano
come sentimenti no global
un tempo erano di una minoranza adesso
stanno diventando sempre più diffusi e
stanno assumendo dimensioni e molto
anche non solo in europa ma per esempio
anche negli stati uniti dove si vogliono
costruire muri quello di cui vi voglio
parlare oggi è un tentativo di spiegare
queste cose attraverso il modo in cui
non forniamo le reti a partire dalla
nostra storia evolutiva cioè come
sapiens
lo abbiamo fatto claudio tuniz ed io in
un piccolissimo libro divulgativo
chiamato homo sapiens una biografia non
autorizzata
un'impresa piuttosto ardita perché non
soltanto perché siamo lui un fisico ed è
un economista ma soprattutto perché si
ha un marito e moglie e quindi io sfido
chiunque di voi a fare una cosa del
genere
restando uniti bene cosa emerge da
questo piccolo lavoro emerge che noi
abbiamo sempre formato reti sociali e
voi direte per forza ma non siamo gli
unici per esempio ci sono altri e
primati che come noi formano delle reti
sociali infatti vedete che questa è una
rete di amici i nostri amici pazze che
sono la specie più vicino a noi dal
punto di vista genetico presi da un loro
conciliabolo si stanno comunicando
qualcosa che cosa distingue noi da loro
innanzitutto sappiamo che abbiamo che
esiste un numero cosiddetto numero di
dumbar che mette in relazione la il
volume del nostro della nostra corteccia
cerebrale con la numerosità dei gruppi
sociali che riusciamo a formare gli
scimpanzé riescono a formare gruppi che
sono al massimo di 50 individui noi con
una corteccia che è tre volte più grande
è facile il conto possiamo formare
gruppi che conosciamo personalmente
di 150 individui e non di più tutti
quelli che chiamiamo amici su facebook
non sono queste ovviamente sono persone
che conosciamo digitalmente
ma allora come abbiamo fatto a formare
gruppi così ampi di persone che si
autodefiniscono per esempio cinesi un
miliardo e 300 milioni di persone oppure
gruppi come quelli che si riuniscono gli
domenica in piazza san pietro a sentire
il papa che fanno riferimento a un altro
miliardi di miliardi di persone che sono
sparsi in tutto il mondo e che si
riuniscono regolarmente per sentirsi
uniti e per essere parte di una
cerimonia collettiva
ecco il segreto della nostra capacità di
formare gruppi noi lo sappiamo bene e si
chiama pensiero simbolico
noi siamo arrivati su questo pianeta
siamo apparsi 200.000 anni fa e per
cento e 30mila anni circa noi abbiamo
manifestato a mente del genere avevamo
già un cervello
adatto a formulare pensiero simbolico ma
non abbiamo mai fatto niente del genere
poi 70 mila anni fa circa
è un periodo piuttosto ampio quello in
cui si sostiene che possa essere nata
questa capacità
noi abbiamo cominciato a fare qualcosa
di strano
abbiamo cominciato a rappresentare il
mondo e lo abbiamo fatto con dei simboli
con delle immagini con delle idee nostre
lo abbiamo rappresentato in molti modi
ma sostanzialmente abbiamo cominciato
prima di tutto a rappresentare rovinate
chi noi stessi prima cosa che vogliamo
rappresentare
abbiamo cominciato a stampare l'impronta
delle nostre mani sulle pareti delle
grotte tutta l'eurasia piena di queste
nostre prime selphy poi abbiamo
cominciato a dipingere noi stessi con
segni sul volto ad aggiornarci con
collana bellissime di conchiglia ne
troviamo in tutta l'africa anche il
medio oriente che risalgono con lo
stesso stile a 80 100 mila anni fa
quindi è una cosa antica questa è
l'immagine molto bella di una nostra
contemporaneo che con questi segni ci
manda dei messaggi ci dice io voglio
rappresentare me stessa con questo tipo
di estetica e voglio dirvi che faccio
parte di una tribù e voglio dire che
sono anche abbastanza fluente perché ho
delle bellissime collane quindi sono una
bella brava madre che appartiene alla
tribù tal d'italia non credete che
questo sia l'atteggiamento tipico solo
di tribù primitive perché noi facciamo
la stessa cosa quando mettiamo la
sciarpa della lazio e andiamo ad un
derby e ci confrontiamo con i nostri
amici della lazio e con i nostri nemici
della roma
mettiamo quindi è più o meno la stessa
cosa e ci rappresentiamo in mille modi
ci rappresentiamo su facebook si ci
rappresentiamo
poi siamo passati a rappresentare il
mondo che ci circonda e l'arte è una
delle cose più utili per questo non
abbiamo cominciato a rappresentare
ma lì che guardavamo la fuori quindi
c'era una realtà osservata e poi una
realtà immaginata che era quella che noi
riuscivamo a trasferire pensate che
questa è la grotta di chauvet in questa
immensa cattedrale naturale di migliaia
di metri quadri ci sono centinaia di
animali
uomini donne animali mitologici che si
muovono se noi mettiamo le torce come
bisognava fare in una grotta di quel
genere in maniera opportuna sotto le
varie aree della grotta poi era come se
noi 35.000 anni fa ci fossimo
raddrizzati per vedere un grandissimo
stupendo cartone animato immaginatevi
l'emozione che poteva nascere da questo
tipo di attività e quindi ci sentivamo
molto uniti probabilmente si celebravano
anche le prime cerimonie chiamiamo le
religiose
a questo punto noi partiamo per la
tangente e cominciamo a immaginarci un
sacco di altre cose per esempio mondi
oltre la vita a mondi
viene di figure mitologiche medley di
mezzi e uomini mezzi e don animali si
inventa questo grande film collettivo
che è costituito da niente dalle
religioni e poi più avanti anche dalle
ideologie sono anch'esse delle cose
assolutamente fantasiose no l'esistenza
di una società di uguali
oppure l'esistenza del libero mercato
vedremo che sarà mercato ma forse non
tanto libero quelle sono le cose che
sicuramente ci uniscono è però ci
dividono anche da qualche altra tribù se
noi ne stiamo su questa nostra natura
così basata sul pensiero simbolico anche
la territorialità che è un'altra
caratteristica che noi condividiamo con
altri primati perché gli altri primati
superamenti sono territoriali a volte
anche più di noi ma anche gli uccelli
sono molto territoriali
noi vediamo che questa è una
caratteristica che noi sviluppiamo si è
stato sostenuto di recente soprattutto
però quando smettiamo di fare i
cacciatori raccoglitori all'interno del
continente di origine non siamo tutti di
origine africana e ci troviamo sulle
coste ad avere questa bonanza di risorse
che non scappano più perché sono risorse
immobili abbondanti in un mondo di
scarsità le risorse abbondanti che altri
magari vorrebbero capire a noi diventa
un elemento essenziale per dire no vale
la pena presidiare il territorio con
gruppi di difesa territoriale che grazie
anche ai segni che c'eravamo inventati
possono essere definiti come i nostri
parenti i nostri conoscenti più qualcun
altro che si segna come noi e così
nascono le prime scaramucce e poi guerre
con altri sapiens che prima non avevano
ragione di esistere perché con altri
sapiens conveniva cacciare insieme
conveniva fare mondo era grande
le prede abbondante oggi naturalmente
le cose per le quali vale la pena
combattere e che sono abbondanti e
concentrate in un mondo di scarsità
possono essere mille altre possono
essere per esempio le risorse
energetiche non rinnovabili si sono
rinnovabili non c'è problema
non possiamo non è necessario combattere
possono essere i nostri diritti
acquisiti possono essere non sa la
nostra ricchezza
temiamo che queste orde che arrivano ci
rubino posto di lavoro ci rubino la
nostra cultura i nostri segni e allora
cosa facciamo
se le cose stanno ancora così
continuiamo a dividerci fra coloro che
restano di coloro che se ne vanno
il mondo è grande io mi fermo sulla
costa dovrebbe cercare un altro posto in
cui vivere
infatti da 70 mila anni fa fino a 50.000
anni fa
arriviamo in australia passando per
l'asia
solo più tardi arriviamo in europa dove
i nostri cugini neanderthal vivevano già
da 300.000 anni e poi spariscono subito
e dopo di che intendiamo una sole
america e questa storia che conosciamo
per molto tempo le cose sono andate
avanti così cioè anche se qualcuno
sviluppava certa territorialità i
corridoi per viaggiare per il mondo non
erano talmente ampi che non ponevano
problemi quando ho cominciato a nascere
il problema del territorio dei confini
quando con l'agricoltura la stanzialità
diventa una scelta obbligata a quel
punto dobbiamo attendere il raccolto
la divisione del lavoro che già esisteva
prima consenta insieme all'agricoltura
di accumulare enormi risorse queste
risorse generate collettivamente vanno
ripartite come bisogna metterci una
regola
e allora nascono qui le varie regole di
razzi eccetera eccetera e soprattutto la
necessità di organizzare uno stato che
garantisca legge e ordine
abbiamo visto questa mattina come questo
può essere molto utile quando la
tecnologia e la scienza
anche a fornire questo servizio e
dall'altra parte bisogna creare
un'identità collettiva bisogna che
quella sciarpa della nostra squadra di
calcio diventi la nostra champa
nazionale 15 che inventiamo un inno
nazionale in cui sentirci tutti simili
ci inventiamo una bandiera un'immagine
no a cui fare riferimento come paese e
la scusa per diventare tutti della
nazione che abbiamo scelto di diventare
la possiamo cambiare a seconda delle
circostanze può essere la lingua sia la
stessa lingua l'etnia abbiamo perso di
una guerra spostiamo il confine di qua
lo mettiamo dall'altra parte no pensate
l'alto adige
quindi questi sono alla fine delle
costruzioni mentali che si inseriscono
in una situazione reale che poi diventa
così cioè quel bellissimo pianeta di
prima noi abbiamo sovrà imposto una
casacca di arlecchino di confini del
tutto immaginari a volte addirittura nel
caso dell'africa del medio oriente
disegnati su una mappa da qualche
generale negli ultimi 50 anni 150 anni
no che si prende un attributo stai di
quattro stai di là poi io mi muovo mano
a prima volevo andare a no non si può
più c'è confine che non si vede però su
questa mappa si deve del confinano e
allora poi ovviamente facendo le cose in
maniera così come dire autoritaria non
sempre questi confine durano a lungo
molto brevemente a questa cosa che è di
tipo territoriale oggi sovrani tornano
una rete di imprese multinazionali di
cui questa foto descrive il controllo
noi parliamo sempre della proprietà ma
questo è il controllo delle imprese
multinazionali e che sono state
selezionate come quelle che hanno la
maggior parte della responsabilità del
prodotto mondiale sono 1400 e 18 imprese
di cui 147 in rosso controllo al 40 per
cento dell'economia mondiale se a questa
rete noi sovrapponiamo
la rete internet di cui abbiamo tanto
parlato in cui i continenti sono vedete
tutti sparsi perché il rosso è un hub
asiatico il il verde e l'europa il blu e
gli stati uniti sono ovunque
bene anche noi diventiamo un organismo
globale in cui la nostra rete
comunicativa si sovrappone alle reti
comunicative che sono tipiche delle
imprese multinazionali che sono anche
reti economiche che si sovrappone alle
reti globale di tipo religioso che si
sovrappone alle reti locali di tipo
nazionale eccetera eccetera eccetera che
noi in questo momento ci troviamo
impigliati in rete di reti e nel farlo
cosa facciamo
abbiamo una espansione economica che ha
caratterizzato soprattutto l'emersione
dalla povertà di 1 miliardo forse due
miliardi di persone danneggiando
ovviamente quelli che adesso si sentono
feriti e che rispondono nel modo che
abbiamo visto il mit cioè opponendo
barriere conclusione noi oggi ci
troviamo ad avere paesi in via di
sviluppo che sono finalmente sviluppati
che stanno imitando al modello di
consumo occidentale e che stanno al
momento consumando un pianeta e mezzo di
risorse non rinnovabili
fra poco saranno due pianeti noi
dobbiamo assolutamente scendere da
quella parte in cui non abbiamo un
ritorno in termini di risorse non
rinnovabili e arrivare a quella
curvatura gialla che quella in cui ci
prendiamo a cuore le sorti della
riproducibilità delle nostre risorse
come facciamo arrivare dalla prima alla
seconda curvatura ci vorrebbe un altro
ted per spiegarvi questo passaggio ma
non serve che è sufficiente prendere
come esempio tutti i discorsi che mi
hanno preceduto
tutto il ragionamento che viene fatto
all'interno di ted è un ragionamento in
cui anziché convincere la gente a
comprare nel vecchio sistema ai vecchi
prodotti ea consumare la terra
noi stiamo lavorando per cambiare le
condizioni di produzione in modo da
arrivare ad una situazione in cui
finalmente potremmo dire ai nostri figli
ecco questo è il pianeta che potremo
ancora lasciarvi